[Music]
because of my work in counterterrorism
I've seen so many of these lessons
around identifying humanity and one
another
unfold overseas and when I came back to
the United States I was really
interested as to whether those same
lessons would apply in daily life here
is it possible to find common humanity
and one another domestically that would
be just as shocking as finding common
humanity with our adversaries was to me
during the war on terror and the answer
is a resounding yes one of the examples
that I really find moving and that
really gives an idea of how powerful
this can be in a community's life is
that of Derek black and this is the
story of a young man who grew up a
teenager with a father who was friends
with David Duke started Stormfront which
is the first and still the largest
neo-nazi online community in the United
States and because even neo-nazis need
online help from their kids when Derek
was a teenager his dad looked to him to
be the webmaster of this dark
hate-filled online community and so
Derek grew up 13 14 15 years old being
the webmaster being the moderator for
discussions of hate online and
eventually having his own podcast that
went out nationwide to this community of
neo-nazis and white supremacists
now when it came time for Derek to
graduate high school he got into college
and when and started at new college in
Florida
liberal arts community and didn't tell
anybody about what his family was known
for about
warm front about his role as the kind of
anointed Prince of the neo-nazi
community in the United States he kept
his head down lived in the dorms made
friends with his next-door neighbors one
of whom was an Orthodox Jew who will be
relevant later in the story so he made
good friends with those around him did
his work but continued to go home and
live this dual life as the webmaster for
four stormfront between his first and
second year the somebody at his college
was doing a paper on the neo-nazi
movement in the United States and in
doing research came across Derek's
profile on storm front and wrote to the
college message board hey this is a
member of our community was anyone aware
of this look at the hate on this website
what should we as a community do about
the fact that this young man is in our
midst he was living in the dorms with us
and the thread is incredibly passionate
and many students are horrified many
advocate for his dismissal and don't
want him in their midst understandably
based on the material that was being
quoted in this discussion Derek come
September went back to school but lived
outside of the dorms off campus he
didn't comment on the thread and
continue to keep his head down and go to
school of course at this point everybody
knows who he is and is avoiding him he
did tenth class and goes home every day
now when from his first year in the
dorms
he had an Orthodox Jewish friend who had
lived on the same Hall as him in the
dorms and this friend said unlike all
everyone else's response here is what I
would like to do I would like to invite
Derek to Shabbat dinner and those of you
my friends who will also share Shabbat
dinner with us I would ask of you one
thing please do not talk to Derek about
this particular issue
anything else is on the table but please
don't raise this issue
with him and for many of the guests it
was a big challenge but those who
attended agreed and Derek came shared a
meal and the next week he was invited
again and again he came and this
continued Friday after Friday after
Friday throughout the year until
eventually one day Derek said of his own
accord you know this is nothing like
what I was raised to believe that it was
you're nothing like the way that I was
raised to believe that you were and he
began to give examples of the crazy
terrible slanderous myths that he had
been raised to believe about the Jewish
community and his new friends said one
by one for each myth let's look that up
together let's see where that myths
began how crazy that is let's all try to
learn its history together and what we
can learn from it and together as a
community they debunked miss after myth
after myth to the point that Derek
initiated a new area of study at the
college that involved building travel
around different societies and
communities but a given student feels
they don't know enough about and
traveling to those countries or to those
regions of the United States to spend
time immersed in other in other cultures
and this got Derek to the point where he
had to remove himself from his family's
life and his father was not accepting of
his change of heart and excommunicated
him from the family and as far as I've
heard last with the story that's where
it stands but Derek is now a leader in
the academic community there at the
college around building study from
language to community to culture to
counteract one's built-in prejudices
through compassionate engagement and
immersion rather than betrayal and
isolation
[Music]